la mode français ses créateurs ses
mannequins ses acheteurs et ses
critiques sont épuisés mais heureux les
défilés de haute couture 84 sont
terminés c'est le styliste de lanvin
jules françois craie qui a reçu tout à
l'heure la récompense le dé d'or de la
haute couture
mais c'est encore une fois yves saint
laurent qui s'attire les dix qui rende
la presse saint laurent legrand france
roche et patrice du tertre nous le
prouve
alors le saint-laurent d'hiver ça sera
comment se demande-t-on sur les plages
en maillot encore neuf rêvait déjà de
fourrure est ce bien raisonnable
182 modèles ont répondu hier à cette
question sous des lustres dorés dans une
ambiance de four la taille elle est à sa
place mais avec des effets de drapés
d'hypocrite
là où le reste de la couture rallonge
saint-laurent raccourci me genou là où
les empiècements s'élargissent il
préconise la robe et hui et les épaules
nues mais un étui à coulisse où se
dessine faux blues
ou faux boli bout ensemble tricolore à
base de noir pour le soir comme partout
dans la couture paillettes d'or sûrs
broderie d or et d argent comme si nous
en avions trop payet sur transparence
retour du velours noir sur poudre look
blanc quant à chris pas ou avec serpent
de diamants taffetas et satin incrustés
et brochets de motifs en relief
ressemblent à des moulures de porte ou
deux places
beaucoup de chapeaux non pas celui ci
celui ci deux curés ou de quaker gros
noeud sur corselet succinct ou peu le
vertige charte mai
en perles
ces dames ont acclamé leurs rives en
criant c'est super c'est génial c'est
trop c'est trop
il en a l'habitude ça doit toujours
faire plaisir